Well,
I have 20 minutes to five.
We can now say the decision taken in
1975 by this country to join.
The common market has been reversed by
this referendum to leave the EU.
You know whether you think brexit is a
good or a bad idea at this point.
One thing is beyond doubt.
It's an idea whose time has come to the
independent United Kingdom.
This isn't something that just happened.
What the world witness last Friday was
the culmination of a pressure movement
that started over 20 years ago,
a movement that has evolved and evolved
across the years and bite it.
It's time exploiting every national and
political crisis to achieve its end.
Now,
of course,
choosing a starting point for this is a
bit arbitrary.
There have been so called euroskeptic
since 1973 when the UK first joined,
what was then called the European
community,
but if I had to pick a date,
I might pick September 20th,
1988.
When Prime Minister Margaret Thatcher
gave a famous speech in Bruge,
laying out a number of the ideas that
would influence euro skepticism for
years to come.
We have not successfully rolled back the
frontiers of the state in Britain own to
see them reimposed,
so tiotropium level with the European
superstate exercising or new dominance
from Brussels.
The result of the speech with something
called the Bruce Group,
a conservative think tank that promoted
rolling back the [inaudible] trend
towards centralization.
Remember,
this was at the end of the Soviet Union
and the world's great experiment with
socialism.
Any form of one party centralization was
a feared prospect by many.
One member of the Bruce Group,
the historian Alan Scott,
took the idea a step further and
launched his own political party.
It was called the Anti federalists
league and it's one aim was to remove
Britain from the EU.
We call Rhonda and affairs.
Nobody can.
This should be old,
too obvious,
but skids party had problems from the
very start.
In 1992,
the anti federalists league went up for
only one seat in parliament and only got
point two percent of the vote,
and it was the same in the European
elections in 1995.
The young movement just lost faith in
[inaudible] ability to lead them and
there were internal arguments about
whether the party which was soon renamed
Ukip or the United Kingdom Independence
Party should remain a single issue,
pressure group or expand into other
issues and become a real party.
That in 1994 arrival,
euro skeptic party called the referendum
party,
exploded onto the scene,
led by a billionaire,
James Goldsmith,
who had no such problems with
infighting.
All he wanted to do was have a
referendum about leaving the EU,
and once they got it,
they would dispatch a politician's
betraying trust by holding a referendum
which is binding on the government.
The referendum party trounced Ukip in
1997,
but both were trounced by Tony Blair and
the rise of New Labor which would hold
the country for the next 13 years.
And yet for those who were looking
closely,
it was possible to see Elaine opening up
for doubt about the EU.
In 92.
Only nine percent thought Britain should
leave the EEC by 97.
That number had risen to 14 percent.
And if you added to those who thought
the EEC should at least reduce its
powers and you have 66 percent of the
electorate expressing some form of euro
skepticism,
there are a number of reasons why Europe
was brought into voters' minds,
but the most significant has got to be
the signing of the master treaty and the
adoption of a single currency.
Something that in 1997,
only 16 percent of Britain's were in
favor of despite these trends,
you can look dead in the water,
but it was about to hit a few strokes of
good luck.
Well,
bad luck for James Goldsmith who passed
away only three months after the 97
election.
Effectively disbanding Ukips only direct
competitor Alan scared was replaced by
more aggressively populous figures like
Nigel Farrage,
who was himself a seat in 1999.
And ironically the European Parliament
by 2001,
despite not winning any parliament seats
in Westminster,
Ukip had become the fourth party in the
UK.
After labor conservatives and the
Liberal Democrats,
their profile rose even more.
When Robert Kilroy Silk,
a former MP and chat show personality
join the
the main issue,
politicians in London decided to open
our doors to a potential 70 million
migrants from eastern Europe.
That $73 million
kilroy silk was a controversial figure
stemming mostly from an article he wrote
called we owe Arabs.
Nothing.
Silk delivered you kips largest victory
in 2004 is European parliamentary
elections coming in third above the
Liberal Democrats,
but more infighting eventually ousted
him from the party within that year.
Yet his example shows the willingness of
UK to engage in the worst forms of
populism,
race,
baiting,
nationalism,
and fear.
Throughout the two thousands and into
the 20 tens,
you kept capitalized on a growing
sentiment among the British people of
national decline in the post colonial
era.
Most keenly felt by the oldest citizens
who made up the core of the vote to
brexit.
They capitalized to on crises like the
financial meltdown in 2008,
the riots that swept the country in
2011,
and now the migrant crisis and
international terrorism,
Ukip and the far right assigned folk
devils to many of these cases like
immigrants,
Muslims,
minorities,
and welfare recipients.
All of these things can bolster
resentful,
nationalism,
but they have to be triggered by
something closer to home.
In this case,
a lot of the research points to the idea
of class trajectory.
I have no
p as all up in my area.
I can't get onto the housing ladder and
have three kids in one room.
A place where I grew up is now was a
lovely area,
but it's now a no go zone.
How are you,
Mike?
I can see my style of living in.
My family's done living,
going down because of this influx that
we can't control.
You can't say that you kept is the soul
force behind Brexit,
but they've been there throughout the
years to help link these real feelings
of falling trajectories to emotions
about national decline and moral panics.
That group,
the public and fear growing from
minuscule routes into a significant
player in the country's politics.
The United Kingdom is not a far right
state with a nationalistic
anti-immigrant and racist people,
but their decision last week to leave
the EU one by a 52 percent,
majority of 72 percent of the population
can be viewed as an expression of a
reactionary far right politics,
and that's the point about far right
political organizations,
they use the fulcrum of populism and
fear to lift many times their weight in
people.
The ideas that animated this vote are
there in Thatcher speech from 1988.
Of course,
the irony is that that's your herself
campaign for Britain to join the EEC the
first time around in 1975.
The even greater irony is that the
unchecked capitalism she championed as
prime minister lead to a form of
globalization that has ravaged the
middle class,
the real cause of the frustration that
you kept exploits to advocate of leaf
foe,
but that's the difference that 40 years
can make.
Brexit,
recontextualizes,
all these small phenomenon threads a
string through them and shows that
transformation doesn't always
have to.
Hey guys,
thanks for watching.
Sorry this is a day late.
Vidcon pushed me back,
but a hankering took responsibility for
it on twitter,
so you can blame him for that.
Um,
if you want to subscribe to this
channel,
Click right here.
And if you want to pledge to this
channel,
help me keep making more videos.
You can click right there on my patriot
and thank you guys so much.
I'll see you next Wednesday for
something new.
Cheers.